hello everyone and welcome to some sad
news from the tata steel chess
tournament daniel dubov has left the
tournament he has been tested positive
for kovid and he will be forfeiting his
last three remaining games uh so what
does this mean for the for the
tournament and for the actual standings
uh all the games that he played so far
remain so all the wins draws and losses
that he got will remain in the
tournament but his last three games uh
against pregnant uh rapport and magnus
carlsen will be forfeited by default and
they will get uh free points uh
as daniel will not be playing so it's a
bit of a shame for the tournament but
there is no better way to handle this uh
as i myself was very much looking
forward to carson versus dubo in the
final round uh not only
okay it's important for the tournament
standings but that's usually a really
really crazy game uh but yeah just
thought i i'd update you guys i don't
really use youtube shorts uh but for
something like this i thought uh it'd be
useful if you guys still haven't heard
about it uh so that's it uh this is
basically the short see you soon